listen that's affinity look lovely thank
you I had a lot of help hours that's
hair and makeup well you look Greta's
dresses it's it's fantastic if it's
vintage or no it's not okay ready it's
got layers and you can fluff it up oh
really
take some space yes you can cover
everything okay so much to talk about
first of all congratulations last man on
earth
is really funny and Fant at people love
it people are losing their minds for it
and you're terrific thank you yeah and
I'm done I'm curious that's going really
well but you're very busy you also just
shot a movie with Robert Redford one of
the great film icons of all time what
was that like yeah Robert Redford and
Nick Nolte and it's called a walk in the
woods okay and it's coming out someday
yeah all right sure coming out someday
coming out someday you are yeah and I
was just on the set for like two days
but they're living legends so I was
trying to soak it all up and Redford
would just be like hey Nick when we got
more time I've got a great story
involving John Steinbeck Marilyn Monroe
and my mom ha ha and then they're like
let's go they're like let's go back to
shooting and I never got to hear any
yeah I'm what about Nick Nolte what's he
like oh he's a character yeah yeah he
was we were talking about New York he's
like yeah I got my star in New York you
know that's night Nolte impression very
good very good
that's my Cookie Monster
like yeah they studied under Grotowski
and you have to have a secret and an
object so for the whole run of the play
I stuck a cork up my ass
does my secret and my object explains a
lot
that corks put in there 50 years yeah it
was Mother's Day and I was talking on
the phone to my mom and Nolte sits down
next to me like oh you talkin to your
mama and I was like yeah it's like happy
Mother's Day not like oh would you mind
telling her that yourself you know
that's obnoxious but it's Nulty right oh
yeah guys like oh yeah yeah so I give
him the phone and he's like having
Mother's Day uh-huh yeah okay you take
care now he handed the phone back to me
and I was like okay bye Maura love you
and and I hope the funny looks at me
like your mama thinks I'm Gary Busey
[Applause]
Oh No dad later I was like boom that was
Nick Nolte she's like I know I love them
from the Amazon commercial
[Laughter]
you